okay so uh leaked decision
politico obtaining the draft decision
the supreme court unless something
changes will be overturning roe v wade
and planned parenthood v casey
this will end federal abortion rights
it will push it to the states
many states will outright ban abortion i
told you yesterday oklahoma passing a
six-week abortion ban that's basically a
total ban most women don't know they're
pregnant until at least four to five
weeks a six-week abortion ban is just an
abortion ban so let's look at some
reactions i want to start with radical
trumpist congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
she started crying when she heard about
the decision
uh let's take a look at that video i
just want to make an announcement and
i'm i'm sorry i'm overwhelmed with
emotion
because
this is the best news of our lifetimes
the supreme court
has voted to overturn abortion rights um
there's a draft opinion out now to
overturn roe versus wade this is a this
is a great victory uh it's a great
victory for god
and the and the unborn who have been
innocently slain
for for years my entire lifetime
and i'll just read this that says roe
was egregiously wrong from the start i
just wanted okay
now i think marjorie taylor green is
completely out of her mind i think she's
nuts i think she's a horrible person but
we have to understand if you believe
abortion is murder right if you believe
that getting an abortion at seven weeks
is the same as a cold-blooded
assassination
it would be logical that you would react
like this and so i think she's nuts for
a whole bunch of different reasons and i
disagree with her view about abortion
completely but let's understand that if
you believed that this is kind of a a
logical reaction the the god stuff is an
extra layer like without the god stuff i
guess you could believe the same thing
but uh so that's marjorie taylor green
laura ingram
says to women who wanted abortion just
moved to a different state this was
always this was a state issue and we
have to say ginsburg said it was shaky
and bad well and i i everyone has to
remember tonight like before everybody
freaks out
that this is now going to be determined
by you the people yeah like you can move
to you could live in new york and you
say look remember new york did that
standing ovation in albany you want to
know what sick is
it's not safe legal and rare anymore in
new york you get a standing ovation for
having abortion up until basically the
baby you know is out of the womb okay so
the reality of course is a lot of people
can't afford to move i mean listen the
same people who uh might be in a
situation where
they might want to seek an abortion and
they would have trouble paying for that
you think they can afford to move to a
different state in order to get it i
mean that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever now laura ingram is aware
that there are some on the left saying
maybe this will inspire
uh the left to get out and vote in
november and it could save the midterm
for democrats she doesn't agree though
the left is going in the stratosphere
tonight they're going nuts
they know their entire facade everything
they fought for this is the die that the
hill that they'll die on they're worried
that it's all going to come crumbling
down
and they think that that somehow this
leak is going to be a gift that could
rescue them for the midterms
well the thinking is misguided all right
so laura ingram says this won't save
democrats in november
uh republican trump is congresswoman
lauren beaubert put out a tweet in
response saying if your response to the
supreme court news is to dust off your
stupid pink hat from 2016 and go march
to a support infanticide
re-evaluate your entire life
and then lastly fox host tomi
says democrats are going to do their own
insurrection over this
uh talking about this leak do you think
that this was an intimidation tactic
absolutely an intimidation tactic and
also a distraction tactic here i think
that the only way the democrats have a
chance in november is if they rile
everybody up get people to the polls
with these emotional cultural issues of
course now what's funny about that is
it's republicans who use contrived
cultural issues to get people to the
polls like critical race theory
this issue of abortion is a real issue
it's about precedent it's about law it's
actually about a supreme court decision
when you have the supreme court actually
dealing with something it's not a
contrived issue the contrived issues are
on their side abortion is one that's
going to be very high emotion very
intense for the country this is their
effort to distract from everything
that's going wrong and play to the
heartstrings of those especially on the
left this support this issue is so
important too and i think we're going to
see the summer 2020 reignited with
protests and dare i say an insurrection
i know that's a dirty word but i think
we're going to see a lot more to come
this week i don't believe that we are
going to see an insurrection or a coup
attempt i think we will hopefully see
democrats say wow
look at what the it it took a few years
right it was i don't know trump hillary
i don't know
and then here's trump and he gets one
pick to the court and then he gets a
second pick and then he gets a third
pick and then mississippi says we're
gonna ban abortion and it's appealed
appealed appealed and then it goes to
the court and well we'll hear from the
court at some point and the court says
roe v wade is gone folks roe v wade is
gone that's it it took some years but
that's the way it ultimately worked
let me know if you believe
this changes the outlook for the
midterms find me on twitter
deepakman
our show has many sponsors i love them
all but there's one product i use more
than any other because i sit on it every
day and that's my all form sofa in my
living room i've had this for three
years now it still looks amazing all
form is the easiest way by far to design
your own custom sofa because unlike with
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape the color
the color of the legs if you're spending
money on a sofa you should be able to
customize every single aspect of what
you want get exactly what you need
another unique thing about all form the
furniture is modular so you can buy one
piece and add to it later rearrange the
pieces
this has so many advantages if you move
if you want to adapt the sofa to a new
space shipping is always fast and free
you've got 100 days to send it back if
you don't love it they all come with a
forever warranty and you'll get twenty
percent off at all form dot com slash
pacman the link is down below